[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
outdoor boys and today we've got a lot
of stuff planned it's gonna be fun I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about what's
coming up here in the near future some
of our upcoming videos give you some
sneak peeks and then I'm gonna answer my
favorite questions and comments from the
internet trolls yep we've got some
absolute gems that have been posted this
week and I just needed to share so first
off I've got a video where me and the
whole family do a taste test of MREs in
various survival foods and we also have
a great baby review video a lot of you
guys have been asking me some questions
about how to pick the right baby when
you're shopping for babies so I went and
did a review of the most expensive and
the cheapest babies on amazon.com so
great video coming up there I also have
this battle ax that I'm working on
restoring as awesome as these videos are
they are not as awesome as the questions
and comments left by the many internet
trolls on one of my latest videos about
a month or so ago I did a video on how
to humanely trap and relocate toddlers
and the video was amazing and it was
everything that you would expect from a
video with that title and YouTube
apparently is digging on it too because
it's been getting 60,000 views a day and
it's just amazing the comments and I
can't even scratch the surface of all
the comments that have been left you've
got to spend some time reading those
comments and they're brilliant okay but
I can tell a lot of people are concerned
and a lot of people want to express
themselves at me so I'm going to take a
moment to answer their questions because
gosh darn it internet trolls are people
too so without further ado I'm gonna
read and answer the best questions and
concerns for my internet trolls
sherrilyn guire asked why did you
through the baby and the toddler well
Cheryl I love my children equally so I
treat them equally I don't want to show
favoritism to one
if you're gonna throw one kid throw them
all Julian arias asked why did you throw
them
WTF well Julian good question
throwing children in sacks helps them
stand conscious in transport fun Tang
said I hate your vid well fun Tang I
think you spelled love wrong Lila black
law said I was a good taller Lyla
no one believes you miss underscore
cuties underscore corner said I am a bit
concerned
you shouldn't have kids well miss
underscore cuties underscore corner I
don't have kids if you'd watch the video
you know I had abandon them in a park so
please watch the whole video before you
leave a comment Julia Irene said if you
really do that to your kids you are
really bad at taking care of your child
this is true Julia but if you really do
this you really don't have kids so does
it really matter
think about lockjaw said it's amazing
YouTube censors haven't caught on this
video yet there's a really good
explanation for that lockjaw YouTube is
owned and run by people who have
children they get it along the similar
lines van tranh said you might be in
jail for that you only need one parent
on the jury one fun time foxy said don't
touch the child exclamation point that's
a good point miss foxy never touch
children they often carry many diseases
that's why I use burlap sacks to
transport the children after trapping
them Clemente mckagan Olli said is this
even legal
with two skeptical emoji faces good
question
Megan Olli check your local state
hunting and trapping regulations to find
out whether trapping children is legal
in your area and make sure you get all
the proper permits and obey all bag
limits and seasons
Stephanie Hughes said how dare you treat
kids like animals and then she has a
purple devil emoji well Stephanie I
figure people treat animals like their
babies so why can't I treat babies like
their animals kind of makes sense if you
think about it I call them my hairless
her babies Breanna Dozier said that's
men don't throw them I don't throw men
Breanna I throw children watch the video
Alexander Gomes said you just throw your
kids exclamation point
Alexander I don't have kids I let them
go remember please people watch the
video and your gamer asked is this a
joke well and your gamer toddler
infestations are no joke
actually one of my internet trolls is
someone who's kind of internet famous
right now it's a member of the IHOP
marketing team mr. buckles roadblock he
said you are dumped I see what you did
there mr. mr. buckles you got you have
turned that upside down Ethan stout asks
what's gonna happen when you realize the
child is dead well Ethan in that
situation you can skip the chloroform
and just go straight to relocation Sachi
Muto said please never kill children
well Miss Muto what if they become
zombies Never Say Never
all the weight underscore me said fake
how in the world and why you throw them
like that
hello way to underscore me I'm concerned
you use the word fake but the rest of
your comment makes me think you may not
understand what that means
idk commented the sad part is that you
guys are actually watching this thanks
for the view and the comment idk I
appreciate the support robox user Emily
eight two eight three zero zero one said
why just why they are your child you're
not a rat you can tell them to clean it
or you can ground them that's a good
point miss eight two eight three zero
zero one but if you think about it
abandoning them at a park is kind of
like grounding them
Troy Avila said you can suffocate a kid
doing by putting them headfirst into a
bag Troy I'd like to see a tutorial
video on that thanks for the suggestion
Layden high and said that's stupid you
are complete dumb
well Layton you might be right but since
my kids have been gone
I can poop by myself and I sleep at
night so it's kind of a win Raziel and
martinez said why you put them in the
bag he probably couldn't breathe
well Rosie no that would explain why my
children died in transport and I had to
use actors to finish the rest of the
video good point
pat pat said you know they could just
reach their hand in the bars and get the
doughnut right
well that's true pat pat but they could
also go to bed without complaining or
pick up their own toys but it ain't
going to happen
Scott Dylan Penna Fleur said that's some
bad parenting better just build a wall
that's right
I'm gonna build a wall and have my kids
pay for it I'm gonna make this house
great again charmander gamer said not to
be rude but you're a kind of kidnapping
kids actually charmander gamer I'm not
kidnapping kids kidnapping is when you
take other people's children what I'm
doing is getting rid of my own children
it's an important difference well here's
an unfortunately angry comment Safa avid
Allah said you're so rude you trapped a
walking baby I don't get it
when did trapping and drugging children
become rude people are very sensitive
nowadays amber jean Dro said you are an
imbecile don't do that that's abusing
your child and those are your children
you imbecile well amber if you had
watched the video you would know that I
don't have children anymore so who is
the imbecile now JP for you Lang said
they could suffocate you idiot well JP
for you lang I doubt they could
suffocate me they were knocked out and
tied up in a bag so that's pretty
unlikely
Brandon Walden commented you just put a
baby in his traveling somewhere I mean
you just don't want to ground the sack
really not responsible well Brandon I
think your Google Translate might have a
virus so if you have a friend who's IT
savvy you might want to have him take a
look at it run antivirus software or
something because nobody understood that
sure you Viets asked he threw a baby did
anyone notice that Asher
unnoticed even LaDuke said you have
actual issues well mister leduc I have
three actual issues but they're in bags
now it's taken care of
IV Wilson said you a horrible daddy
well I be I'm not a daddy anymore I'm
just a horrible person deathclaw boy
said I pooped on my own face Gill Radley
poo said I reported this video thanks
Gil Radley poo that's pretty darn close
to a share I appreciate the support
Isaac barn hat also expressed his
concern
he said idiot you would do that you
should love them well Isaac sometimes
when you love someone you've got to let
him go Darin Morgan said look what he
does to it the children he is gonna
smuggle them so Darren you're saying I'm
a smuggler you know I did the Kessel run
in 12 parsecs Matt Swensen said you're a
child abusing well Matt I'm 39 years old
I'm hardly a child
Joshua Imagi from Queens New York said
what if they cry till they vomit
well Joshua that's why you put them in
the bags
Kelly Truong asked are you killing kids
mean no Kelly I'm killing them nice Finn
see simply commented with 23 thumbs down
emojis I responded with 45 thumbs up
emojis in your face Flynn I am
everything said I hate you as a dad even
though it's probably a joke your mom has
free doughnuts waiting for you the front
yard kid Alvin best asked why would you
smell that dirty Dipper well Alvin
tasting diapers is gross just stick to
smelling them sketcher is awesome
friends said child abuser you just kept
throwing them like you don't care throw
your kids in the air like you just don't
care what well guys that is all I have
time for I wish I could show you all the
stupid comments people have left but
please go check out the video go click
on the link below read the comments and
vote for your favorite cheeky
response to stupid comments and if you
have some of your own feel free to leave
them they make for some great reading
thanks for watching guys hope you
enjoyed this video and don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning and we got great
stuff coming up thanks for watching we
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor voice youtube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video